[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro du 7 8 sociétés
nous aborderons la reconnaissance
faciale vous n'êtes pas dans un film de
science fiction mais bien sûr tv 78 à
l'heure de l'intelligence artificielle
la reconnaissance faciale devient un
enjeu majeur pour la société elle les
entreprises et l'état
une technologie qui fascine autant
qu'elle interroge et parfois qui
inquiète pour en parler avec nous ce
soir est dj béchère bonsoir soit vous
êtes députée elle la république en marge
de la première circonscription des
yvelines
face à vous il chemla cofondateur de
united biometrics incubés sur le plateau
de saclay absolument
bonsoir la reconnaissance faciale est
déjà dans notre quotidien certains
d'entre vous dérivés déverrouille son
téléphone et grâce à la reconnaissance
faciale ou procède des paiements
bancaires avec l'intelligence
artificielle cette technologie a connu
un fort gain en performances ces
dernières années et grâce aux progrès
des algues au rythme lié à l'utilisation
de l'apprentissage profond appelé deep
learning et des technologie des capteurs
didier baichère vous êtes rapporteur de
la note scientifique sur les enjeux de
la reconnaissance authentifié ou
identifier des personnes
oui effectivement lancer un sujet donc
en tant que vice président de l'office
des sciences et technologies de
l'assemblée nationale sur lequel on a on
a souhaité se pencher en particulier
parce que on est typiquement dans une
dans une technologie qui à un moment
donné
à travers ces usages impacte directement
le choix de société qu'on aura demain ou
qu'on voudra faire demain et donc on a
on a souhaité avec ce rapport en fait
faire le un peu l'état de l'art de ce
qui se faisait en matière scientifique
mais aussi des conséquences et donc il
nous a amenés à faire un saut nombre de
recommandations très précises en matière
d'expérimentation et de consultation
citoyenne pour que le débat puisse
s'ouvrir assez largement sur ces sujets
il ya des enjeux
économique il ya des enjeux d'emploi
évidemment nous avons des champions
français et européens qui travaillent
sur ces sujets là et donc c'est
important un moment donné qu'on puisse
se positionner les collectivités locales
aussi un moment donné avec la
vidéoprotection se sont posé ces
questions sont face aussi à des choix
technologiques de caméra voir
d'intelligence artificielle de solutions
techniques à un moment donné elles sont
un peu livrée à elle même et donc
c'était important de pouvoir se
positionner maintenant sur le site
d'airbus à elancourt le groupe déploie
une stratégie en tissant des
collaborations avec des entreprises
c'est le cas avec united biometrics créé
en 2014 est incubé sur le plateau de
saclay cette entreprise est spécialisée
dans la sécurité des accès numérique
avec de la biométrie notamment la
reconnaissance faciale
comment ça marche et fiable à ce système
alors ce qu'on a comme système bien sûr
pour l'utilisateur final c'est un
pouvoir s'enrôler très facilement avec
une toute une chaîne de sécurité à
l'enrôlement puisqu'on peut pas si on
enregistre quelqu'un d'autre par rapport
à la personne qu'on doit authentifié par
la suite
c'est un problème donc à une chaîne de
sécurité très sophistiqué l'enrôlement
qui est mise en place au départ et
ensuite d'authentification elle doit se
faire de manière simple rapide efficace
et c'est ça qu'on cherche aujourd'hui
pour l'utilisateur ça doit être
transparent la boîte noire qui est
derrière on s'en occupe et elle protège
donc ce joueur chez nous l'identité de
l'utilisateur
on ne sait pas qui vous êtes sur nos
solutions et les biométrique nous
utilisons quelle qu'elle soit le faciale
entre autres même s'il ya de
l'intelligence artificielle
on ne pourra donc un cas remonter au
visage de la personne et c'est ça le but
de united biométrique c'est de protéger
l'utilisateur final tout en donnant le
résultat attendu au banc aux grandes
entreprises qui veulent utiliser nos
solutions et cette solution a été
intégrée dans les terminaux fabriqués
par airbus et peut-être dans les futures
dans les futurs terminaux de la police
alors
est bien évident que nous nous avons
travaillé avec airbus pour intégrer nos
technologies sur un de leur terminal qui
a la foi et utilise la bande police
radio et donc les bandes classique 3g 4g
etc
donc nous avons intégré nos technologies
dessus libre airbus de vendre aux
clients nationaux tels que le
gouvernement la police les pompiers etc
alors c'est un marché porté par
l'augmentation des activités de lutte
contre la criminalité et le terrorisme
cette technologie c'est une priorité
pour le gouvernement dans ce contexte
c'est pas une question de de priorité
par rapport à la sécurité souvent et
vous avez raison de le présenter comme
ça il ya des raccourcis qui sont faits
en matière de reconnaissance faciale
versus la sécurité comme si la
reconnaissance faciale ne servait que
des sujets de sécurité
c'est un des cas d' usage dans dans le
rapport et dans le travail que nous
faisons actuellement avec le
gouvernement
on a identifié quatre cas d' usage très
différents le premier 15 usage on
parlait d'un roulement c'est à dire est
ce qu'un billet à un moment donné peut
être dématérialisé est ce que votre
visage peut devenir votre billet soit
pour rentrer dans un train soit pour
rentrer dans un avion les deuxième cas
d'usagé tous les cas de sécurité
effectivement qui existent déjà comme le
système paraphe dans les aéroports où on
compare l'image qui est sur votre
passeport et la vidéo qu'on voit en
direct troisième cas d'usagé tous les
cas d'usagés marketing qui à mon avis
poseront beaucoup de questions quand on
fera la la consultation citoyenne c'est
à dire vous rentrez dans un restaurant
et compte tenu de la morphologie que
vous avez est ce qu'on va vous pousser
une offre non-sollicitée d'un menu
important parce que vous semblez être
gros ou dans un magasin qui vend des
cosmétiques vous semblez être vieux et
donc du coup on va vous pousser des
crèmes antirides il quatrième cas d'
usage qui est extrêmement important et
d'ailleurs qu'on n'avait pas envisagé au
démarrage et qu'on a rajouté c'est tous
les cas qui tourne autour de la santé et
du social
donc la santé c'est s'assurer qu'on a le
bon patient quand on va faire une
opération jusqu'au bout il ya beaucoup
plus d'erreurs qu'on s'imagine et tous
les cas qui tourne autour du social
c'est par exemple si on encourage de
plus en plus à vieillir à la maison on
sait qu'à un moment donné on peut être
dans une difficulté peut-être perdre un
peu la tête
si jamais vous vous perdez en ville vous
pourriez de manière volontaire donnez
votre photo à un service municipal par
exemple qui utiliserait de la
vidéoprotection et de l'intelligence
artificielle par dessus pour vous
retrouver beaucoup plus facilement et
des exemples qui ont été faits
dans le cas des expérimentations de la
ville de nice qui sont très intéressants
il n'y a pas que des casses sécuritaire
sur la reconnaissance faciale je pense
que c'est important
il ya beaucoup de fantasmes aussi autour
de la reconnaissance faciale et l'idée
d'expérimenter à plus grande échelle et
de lancer cette consultation citoyenne
avec la population c'est aussi faire la
pédagogie pour expliquer ce qu'est la
reconnaissance faciale et ce qu'elle
n'est pas nous ne sommes ni aux états
unis ni en chine nous avons des
protection des libertés individuelles en
france et en europe qui sont très
importantes on ne peut pas se retrouver
dans la situation des états unis ou de
la chine qui sont souvent comme pris ce
qu'ils sont souvent pris comme mauvais
exemples auxquels encore une fois nous
ne nous pouvons pas nous rattacher alors
justement que pensez-vous de la
reconnaissance faciale nous avons posé
la question aux yvelinois écoutez moi ça
me va coûte bien puisque je téléphone
qui va avec
donc je m'en sers il sera marche très
bien ça facilite les choses
dès que tu pour tenter dé fois que tu le
sors et c'est bon t'es déjà je trouve
que c'est bien aussi déverrouiller avec
un code n'est pas obligé
de montrer sa tête pour déverrouiller un
téléphone ça sert à rien de faire des
technologies qui n'ont pas de but ça
dépend si on est fiché après avec ça les
données personnelles des x sont utilisés
justement revendu donc c'est peut être
un danger en faute si je me fais piquer
mon téléphone le voleur aura plus de mal
utiliser ou même à le revendre pour moi
personnellement ça n'a vraiment pas un
intérêt particulier on met de plus en
plus d'infos et de données personnelles
sur le téléphone donc forcément la
reconnaissance faciale ça peut être
utile je suis très inquiet ça peut être
dans des régimes totalitaires un moyen
extrême monstrueux de savoir où sont les
gens qui sont les gens ce qu'ils font ça
peut être une atteinte à la démocratie
une réaction oui c'est d'une grande
maturité en fait c'est intéressant ce
que les gens vous avez interviewé 10
on a fait un sondage avec l'ifop pour
renaissance numérique donc on peut
retrouver le détail de ce sondage sur le
site de renaissance numérique et ses
remontrances à être qu'à une très grande
connaissance de la reconnaissance
faciale tout le monde a un avis sur la
reconnaissance faciale
par contre quand on creuse un peu dans
le détail on voit que ça soulève un
certain nombre de questions sur la
future société que nous voulons
hélas souvent mélangés un petit peu tout
et encore une fois on pousse beaucoup
pour que cette consultation citoyenne
effective qu'ils soient qu'ils soient
lancées par par le gouvernement pour que
tout un chacun puisse bien comprendre
les quatre cas d' usage dont je parlais
tout à l'heure
bien comprendre comment on protège les
libertés individuelles et les données
biométriques aujourd'hui en europe et en
france parce que c'est un sujet qui est
éminemment européen qui n'est pas
uniquement français et si on veut faire
le poids face aux états unis à la chine
c'est important que ce soit un sujet
européen
donc là il ya énormément de choses qui
sont en train de se mettre en place
donc j'espère moi je pose beaucoup pour
qu'ils nous aident expérimentation qui
se met en place pourquoi une loi
d'expérimentation tout simplement pour
que sur ce sujet aussi sensible on
puisse bien cadrer les choses on dise
qu'est ce qu'on va faire avec qui dans
quels délais avec quelle collectivité
avec quel industriel pour s'assurer que
n'est pas de fantasmes autour de la
manipulation des données puisque on veut
avoir une approche transparente et
éthique de cette reconnaissance faciale
l'a entendu justement une inquiétude sur
les données personnelles et notamment
sur la liberté d'aller et de venir
anonymement
c'est une crainte pour les usagers alors
je dirais que il ya deux de manière de
regarder les choses d'abord une
technologie est forcément neutre c'est
surtout l'utilisation qu'on en fait qui
porte en négatif ou qui vend poser en
positif donc ça c'est la première chose
que je dirais déjà aujourd'hui on
on a un certain nombre de téléphones
mobiles dans nos poches
et si on veut vous suivront ces vous
suivra 30 mètres près toute la journée
donc ça c'est aussi une chose qui existe
déjà peut-être que les gens ne savent
pas mais ça ça existe déjà
donc on sait où nous sommes parce qu'un
téléphone c'est très individuel on a
peur du faciale parce que c'est notre
identité c'est notre propriété c'est
quelque chose qui a une autre valeur
pour les gens et ça je comprends tout à
fait et c'est pour ça que nous
aujourd'hui ce que nous proposons c'est
des solutions d'authentification et non
des solutions d'identification
donc ne reconnaître quelqu'un par
rapport à une donnée qu'on a stocké et
savoir que c'est la bonne personne pour
faire une transaction
c'est ou avoir accès à un site où il ya
des informations confidentielles ou il
ya ces impôts etc
c'est une chose suivre les gens dans la
rue c'est un autre modèle
on s'y attache pas aujourd'hui c'est un
autre modèle et si on peut s'arrêter
deux secondes sur ses libertés
on est aussi face à nos propres
contradictions c'est à dire qu'on va
avoir une réticence très très forte et
je vous rejoins par rapport à la
reconnaissance faciale parce que c'est
votre visage
mais à côté de ça vous avez beaucoup de
gens qui ont joué avec fameuse
application faith
ap donc il permettait de se vieillir en
direct en fait quand vous avez fait ça
sans vous en rendre compte vous avez
donné l'ensemble de vos données
biométriques de visage à une société
russe quand vous vous amusez ce qui est
interdit en france à rechercher vos
origines en donnant votre adn en faisant
vous savez les testant ligne pour savoir
si vous avez des origines asiatiques
européennes etc
c'est un côté récréatif que les gens
font spontanément quand vous faites ça
vous donnez votre adn ce qui est
probablement la données biométriques la
plus sensible à des sociétés américaines
donc il faut que chacun aussi
comprennent que on est on est très
ambivalents par rapport à ces sujets et
on a un travail de pédagogie est aussi
d'enseignement parce que je parle
d'enseignement l'économie de la donner
dans le rapport pour s'assurer que les
jeunes très tôt comprennent que les
données ce sont des éléments qui font
partie d'une économie mondiale
généralisée et c'est une donnée qui est
gratuite souvent et il ya des
professionnels qui gagnent beaucoup
d'argent donc faut être extrêmement
vigilant avec ses propres données
cette fois un bouleversement pour les
usagers il ya ce jour un million et demi
de caméras installées sur l'ensemble du
territoire français dont 150 milles sur
la voie publique
créer des seuils f-city des villes
sécurisé est ce que c'est le but à terme
c'est la question en tout cas qui m'a
amené à regarder cet usage c'est à dire
que la vidéoprotection elle est déjà
installée dans les villes aujourd'hui
vous avez des humains donc des policiers
municipaux le plus souvent qu'ils
regardent la circulation qui peuvent
éventuellement se surveiller des zones
dans les villes donc la question qui se
pose c'est est ce que il faut remplacer
ces personnes humaines par un logiciel
par une brique logicielle d'intelligence
artificielle qui éventuellement pourra
faire de l'aide à la décision plutôt que
fait par des humains aujourd'hui il ya
énormément de billets qui existent par
rapport à ces humains qui regarde des
images et où est ce qui le regarde
est ce que demain un algorithme me
permettrait d'avoir moins de billets
aujourd'hui au niveau scientifique
c'est ce que je dis dans le rapport que
j'ai réalisé au mois de juillet c'est
qu'il n'ya pas de données suffisamment
importantes pour pouvoir dire le
logiciel d'intelligence artificielle
propose moins de billets que l'être
humain est donc c'est pour ça qu'on
souhaite expérimenter pour s'assurer que
les algorithmes en tout cas français et
européens que des sociétés comme la
vôtre pourrait développer vont pouvoir
s'entraîner un moment donné sur un
maximum de données françaises et
européennes pour s'assurer qu'on va
lever le plus de biais possibles
aujourd'hui ça n'est pas le cas et vous
souhaitez également une consultation
nationale sur le modèle des états
généraux de la bioéthique en
interrogeant les français tirés au sort
pour répondre justement à ces questions
c'est important en fait de d'avoir ce
qu'on appelle une consultation citoyenne
effective nous c'est ce qui s'est passé
dans le cadre des lois de bioéthique
donc à chaque fois que vous avez une
modification potentiel sociétal
anthropologique
c'est important d'avoir cette
consultation à la fois en ligne à la
fois avec des réunions publiques mais
aussi en tirant des français au sort qui
vont pouvoir analyser l'ensemble des
données qui vont être à disposition et
avec les c'est l'ensemble de ces données
dans le cadre des lois de bioéthique qui
ont permis de construire le texte de loi
de bioéthique nous avons validé à
l'assemblée nationale et qui ont une
dernière discussion au sénat
actuellement et qui permet je pense de
passer de manière apaisée
un sujet qui touche à la transformation
de notre société parce qu'on aura
interrogé énormément de monde et qu'au
moment de cette interrogation on fait la
pédagogie sur ce que nous voulons faire
et ce que permet ou ne permet pas cette
technologie pour faire tomber l'ensemble
de ses fantasmes et il y a eu
plusieurs expérimentations une menée à
nice en février 2010 9 lors du carnaval
pendant trois jours elle la mairie à
tester en conditions réelles le
dispositif de reconnaissance faciale et
auparavant en 2017 il y avait également
eu un test lors du carnaval de notting à
londres un logiciel avait cru identifier
trente cinq suspects dans la foule or
c'était 35 erreur c'est un système qui
n'est donc pas infaillibles et fiemme là
comme tous les systèmes maison besoin de
tuning ils ont besoin de précisions ils
ont besoin d'améliorations vous citiez
tout à l'heure l'appel à la technologie
d'apprentissage profond le dip learning
effectivement tout dépend pour avoir un
logiciel performant la faim en
exploitation il faut avoir vraiment
construit le modèle andy planning c'est
ce que nous on chez une attelle
biométrique pour avoir le maximum de
performance et je le répète tout en
protégeant l'identité et les données
biométriques ça c'est quelque chose qui
nous appartient et qui est protégé par
des brevets internationaux pour nous en
fait si la solution de deeper ning est
mal faite
si on n'a pas passé suffisamment de
temps à donner à manger à ce moteur
d'apprentissage d'accord c'est à dire
qu'on a il a acquis des compétences et
plus on va lui faire acquérir de
compétences plus va être performant en
exploitation si on oublie cette phase là
ou si elle est belle passe et fait un
peu trop courts ou si la base de données
biométriques n'est pas suffisamment
large on n'aura pas un logiciel
performant donc ces logiciels
aujourd'hui on pourrait aussi profiter
des expérimentations comme vous le
proposez d'approfondir en temps réel sur
les données acquises pendant ces
expérimentations et réinjectés dans le
moteur de machine learning ces
informations pour les retraités à voir à
la fin un logiciel qui fait ce qu'on lui
demande pas plus à nous après entre le
législateur et les industriels
de trouver les fonctionnalités du
logiciel adapté à ce que veut la
population est ce que vaut la
réglementation locale française et
européenne donc pour que ça soit plus
fiable une fois de plus en plus des
données
didier baichère vous ne craignez pas une
pression des industriels
mais la pression deux industriels ça
aussi c'est souvent un fantasme vous
savez on est les parlementaires on est
tout à fait indépendants dont j'ai
interviewé énormément de scientifiques
énormément d'industriels ce qui est
important c'est essayer de comprendre ce
qu'ils font comprendre les enjeux et est
ce que la france doit se positionner au
sens économique du terme sur ces sujets
là où laisser passer les trains moi moi
je ne conçois pas un moment donné que
sur une technologie que nous utilisions
déjà puisque pour déverrouiller
téléphone dès les spectateurs l'ont très
bien présenté je je ne conçois pas en
terme de souveraineté nationale
qu'on soit détendre dépendant uniquement
de sociétés chinoises de solution
chinoise et de solutions américaine nous
devons avoir une solution française et
européenne ne serait ce que parce que
les collectivités locales vous l'avez
très bien dit sur la vidéoprotection
vont vouloir avoir des recommandations à
un moment donné sur les outils qu'elles
peuvent utiliser et si nous n'avons pas
des champions français sur ces sujets là
nous serons dépendants de puissance
étrangère ce qui de mon point de vue sur
sur la reconnaissance faciale n'est pas
du tout souhaitable
alors justement vous parlez de puissance
étrangère à la zone asie-pacifique
s'impose comme la région du monde où sa
croissance est la plus rapide avec la
chine et l'inde en tête
le comité d'organisation des jeux
olympiques de 2020 qui auront lieu à
tokyo prévoit d'utiliser des portiques
dotés de dispositifs de reconnaissance
faciale afin de contrôler justement les
accès réservé aux joueurs aux membres du
personnel et aux journalistes en france
est ce que ça peut être le cas pour les
jo de 2024
mais c'est un enjeu essentiel c'est à
dire que on est à saint quentin en
yvelines
donc on est particulièrement concernée
par les jeux olympiques est-ce qu'il
faut avoir en tête c'est que vous avez
des athlètes et des équipes des athlètes
qui vont naviguer entre la plaine
ni donc le 93 et saint quentin en
yvelines donc si vous voulez avoir un
flux pour que pour que l'accès en fait
aux manifestations soient correctes ça
me semble très très compliqué de ne pas
avoir une solution de reconnaissance
faciale sécurisé qui soient proposées
parce que quand vous allez commencer à
prendre les transports entre le 93 il 78
il risque de se passer beaucoup de
choses c'est pour ça que tokyo a mis en
place cette solution de facilité donc si
nous on souhaite est au même niveau que
les jeux olympiques de tokyo
il faut encore une fois que c'est fait
cette expérimentation ait lieu il faut
qu'on fasse travailler là reconnaît la
reconnaissance faciale et logiciels de
reconnaissance faciale français et
européens pour proposer notre propre
solution et ça sera possible d'ici 2024
vous pensez y film là sans problème sans
problème les solutions fonctionnent déjà
aussi bien chez moi que chez nos
concurrents en ans qu'elle existe
il ya déjà des solutions qui existent
pour le burning passe automatique quand
vous rentrez dans un avion et je parle
de la concurrence je propose pas ce type
de solution mais on suit quand même
l'activité
on a bien ce genre de reconnaissance
automatique
on pourra peut-être associer un groupe
de billets à la personne qui l'a acheté
ou si elle veut pas qu'ils donnent une
délégation de pouvoir une personne qui
va mener le groupe pour prendre la place
dans un stade
il faut qu'on ait un maximum de sécurité
sur ces événements je voudrais pas
rappeler les malheureuses anniversaire
qu'on vient de passer sur ce qui s'est
passé au stade de france et en france il
ya quatre ans maintenant on ne peut pas
se permettre d'avoir ce type d'événement
sur un événement mondial de cette taille
la sécurité oui fait n'importe comment
certainement pas donc à nous de
contrôler ça avec le législateur le plus
propre monde landes et dernière point ce
système de reconnaissance faciale
est-ce que ça a incarné par un peu ce
rêve d'une société entièrement
informatisé un peu des villes du futur
mais ça c'est encore une fois dans
dans l'idée de la consultation c'est
aussi avoir la possibilité de dire
quelle est la société que nous voulons
demain si tout le monde veut ralentir si
on veut arrêter la vidéoprotection dans
nos villes si on veut plus avoir ces
solutions pour gagner du temps on était
les spectateurs vous avez interviewé
allons très bien pourrait présenter
parce qu'on gagne du temps le téléphone
vous reconnais plus vite on accède plus
vite d'un avion plus vite à un train bon
mais c'est un choix encore une fois de
société moi je ne suis pas en tant que
parlementaire là pour dire si c'est bien
ou pas bien
la technologie permet de le faire
maintenant est ce que nous souhaitons
utiliser les éléments les plus positifs
de cette technologie et de s'assurer
qu'ils effectivement en france et en
europe
nous ne construirons pas une société de
la sécurité et de la surveillance
généralisée ce qui est le cas le
probablement en chine donc pour se
défendre par rapport à ça nous devons
construire notre pas ce que j'appelle la
voix française la voie européenne et
construire cette reconnaissance faciale
avec de l'intelligence artificielle à la
fois transparence c'est-à-dire
transparente on sait ce qui est à
l'intérieur
en terme de deux briques logicielles et
éthiques
nous qui ne va pas aller au delà des
principes que les françaises et les
français auront choisi pour la société
de demain et vous ne craignez pas une
fracture du numérique
à un moment donné c'est pas la
reconnaissance faciale qui engendrera la
fracture numérique la fracture numérique
c1 c'est un sujet en soi
on le voit bien sur l'axé pour ne serait
ce que pour payer ses impôts en ligne et
on voit chaque année il ya des
difficultés et il faut c'est pour ça
qu'on crée les maisons france services
pour que partout sur le territoire les
françaises et les français puissent
avoir accès à un service public qui
proposera aussi du numérique mais il n'y
a pas de lien entre la reconnaissance
faciale son développement et la fracture
numérique
elle ne en tout cas elle ne l'augmentent
pas par rapport à ce qui existe déjà
aujourd'hui j'ai envie de rajouter
quelque chose pourquoi parce que là on
est en train de mélanger deux choses on
est en train de mélanger identification
c'est à dire j'ai une reconnaissance
faciale
je reconnais un individu jugé son nom
son prénom son adresse et tout son
pedigree il est y compris peut-être
l'accès à son
comment on vous dira ce qu'il a fait en
esquisse et c'est donc là ça peut être
intéressant et l'authentification simple
quand on vend des billets donc on en
achète des billets pour rentrer dans un
stade
est-ce que j'ai besoin de savoir que ces
îles celle là où quelqu'un d'autre
forcément j'ai besoin de savoir c'est
bien la bonne personne qui a acheté le
billet et que donc il est autorisé à
rentrer on n'est pas obligé d'avoir dans
le même moment
après on peut chercher on peut
développer aussi s'il ya de la fraude et
des choses comme ça aussi à des risques
mais au même moment on n'a pas forcément
besoin d'avoir l'identité de la personne
reconnaître une personne oui
l'authentifier oui comme quoi c'est le
porteur de l'acte etc
c'est une chose l'identifier on rentre
dans la police donc à nous de gérer
l'éventail de la solution est de couper
là où on a besoin on n'est pas besoin de
développement n'a pas besoin de
développer de soufre et de suite tout le
monde en permanence enfin c'est ce que
j'aimerais amener des marins il faut
redire aux gens qui nous écoutent que en
france ce qui n'est pas le cas aux états
unis et en chine ce qui nous différencie
très largement en france pour pouvoir
accéder à l'ensemble de ces données il
faut une commission rogatoire donc il
n'y a qu'un juge aujourd'hui qui peut
demander à une ville ou à la ratp ou
sncf ou un aéroport peu importe à avoir
accès à des données vidéo ça ne peut
être que dans le cadre d'une enquête
parce que dans le cadre d'une enquête
on a les empreintes digitales la photo
de quelqu'un donc c'est uniquement un
juge qui peut faire ça ne s'agit pas du
tout de déroger à ça un jour on souhaite
rester dans dans ce cadre là et que
c'est un un juge dans le cadre d'une
enquête criminelle judiciaire un moment
donné il peut demander l'accès à des
données personnelles ce qui n'est pas le
cas aux états unis et en chine je prends
souvent l'exemple des états unis
aux etats unis quand vous avez 15 ans
vous passer votre permis de conduire et
une photo sur votre permis de conduire
l'état fédéral aspyr la photo du permis
de conduire sont jamais vous demander
votre avis en france ça n'existe pas et
en europe ça n'existe pas bien
heureusement je dirais que la protection
des personnes est très intéressante la
reconnaissance faciale donne une
dynamique comme on l'a cité plusieurs
fois tout de suite sur le fait qu' une
personne puisse être reconnue facilement
saf lui dit
qui les accès les trafics et c est
encore une fois je reviens un sur la
protection des données personnelles de
la protection de la biométrie elle même
comment cette biométrie à les stocker ou
est ce qu'elle est stocké comment elle
est traitée
ça aussi ça apporte des avantages dans
nos solutions où les données sont non
pas laisser brut mais complètement
transformé et de manière irréversible
c'est à dire que ce que nous stockons
nous sur nos machines ou ou même sur les
téléphones airbus sécurisé qu'on a vu
c'est une donnée transformé aujourd'hui
nous n'avons pas envie par exemple dans
le cas d'airbus si on donne ça aux
militaires aussi en hausse à la police
que la personne qui s'authentifie sur
une base de données quelconque ou même
sur un réseau on sache que ce soit un
général le président de la république ou
la chef de groupe de la police nous ce
qui est intéressant c'est de bien voir
que cette personne a l'autorisation de
faire et donc elle est authentifié pour
ça merci la distinction est passé merci
messieurs pour votre participation
c'est la fin de ce sept huit sociétés
très belle soirée sur tv 78
[Musique]
il